every jak nation it's greg alba here and
i'm john essentially what we wanted to
do was show you guys our live event but
there was a lot going on and we had a
lot to make sure was in order before the
live event started so we couldn't really
get a proper angle and the place we were
shooting from was pretty dark to begin
with so basically what we ended up with
was all a lot of audio and not a lot of
great video but we still wanted to share
it with you guys so we thought we'd
throw it up here in podcast format along
with a couple brief snippets from the
clips that we showed just to give you a
sense for which scenes we chose and what
not and if you want to see the full
scenes they're all detailed down in the
description box as well as the pain
comment yeah so the audio is not
entirely the greatest thing in the world
we was such a frantic night very much a
first-time affair for this is our first
live event and we had pretty much sold
out the theater so we were pretty
anxious about it that we didn't even
think about it can we record the audio
through the microphones that we're doing
this into we got to make sure the camera
is all set up like there was so much in
there that we were just forgot to take
care of that day if we ever do another
live event like this one we will
definitely make sure the audio was a lot
better like this intro audio is sounding
a lot better than the audio you guys
well actually here however we listen to
it and you know if you just settle into
it you can easily pay attention to
what's going on and so you guys were not
confused by how the event went down it
was at the arena Center lounge movie
theater I want to thank Christian
Maloney Milioti
we're gonna be Christian maoli if I'm
not mistaken yeah the Peter and Stacy
Howard who helped coordinate the event
and Brianne Chandler so what we
essentially did was we did Brianne
Chandler's film therapy segment where
she basically asks us real personal
questions that's somehow linked to film
in our lives and we had one more
question just for the live event as well
inserted into there and to make it a
little bit more spicy we put movie clips
in between each one of our answers so
Brianne would ask me a the question I'd
answer it then I played
clip of the movie that I'm really
referring to something that really
resembles the answer but because this is
YouTube we can't show you the whole clip
yeah we can only give you like little
taste of it so you'll have some audio so
that way you know specifically what
scene were referring to in which movie
we are talking about but we did want to
share this with you guys because people
did come out and Brienne put a lot of
work into hosting the event as well so
big thanks to her once again and thank
you to everyone who did show up everyone
who did come out incredibly grateful
because it was one hell of an experience
that we had we get pretty vulnerable in
here and I don't think either of us are
really expecting to get so personal so
vulnerable and the ground certainly
wasn't expecting it's like this big is
big hybrid of vulnerability and laughs
vulnerability and lapsed so if you want
to get to know us a little bit better
just sit back relax and enjoy the next
about 50 minutes or so yeah enjoy and
leave some comments below thanks guys as
with every session of film therapy I
have guest patients and my guest
patients today are the real rejects
[Applause]
we're here social media is important
those are pretty amazing intro and I
didn't know how to all of that up but
I'm here you're here now agent Lee have
you guys ever been to like a premiere
for a movie for like a friend's movie no
and then you're like man that was
terrible
yeah but the person who made it is so
proud of that I don't know if we're
having that moment what time do we
finish it is like 3:00 a.m. last night
the computer dropped like a good amount
of our sequence from the timeline like
right as we were about to put everything
together so you know we had like the
last-minute frantic we got to figure
this thing out we lost like two scenes
so yeah I want to i before the live
event is like so I'm sure many of you
probably all of you have never joined us
for film therapy but here's how it's
gonna work I'm gonna ask these gentlemen
three questions about film they're the
same three questions each and every time
and we're gonna add an additional fourth
question just for this is today a
wild-card question so the regular three
questions are what is that film that
inspires you what does a film or a scene
from a film that triggers a memory for
you maybe it's happy maybe it's painful
and what does the film that helps you
through difficult times and the one that
you asked me to add is also with a film
character that kind of represents who
you are yeah so yes man you know you're
sure I want both of you guys to keep
pointing the mics at me let's go ahead
and get started with our first question
which is what is the film that inspires
you which one would you like you would
like to go first
well we set up this little slide show
Jen pull up that first question if
you're out there mom dear no she watch
look at the scroll at the bottom so you
know where she's at
so we didn't know when attendees
just keep watching that yeah just let it
play Jim we just want to puff this
question on here
yeah don't work yeah so we give her
notes you guys we just keep getting
played champ what is the film that
inspires you my film is a very cliche
answer and that is definitely the first
rocky movie I remember when I was a kid
and I watched it I ended up bidding it
like pretty much right away and I think
especially down the road that film
specifically really hit a strong heart
in my heart hey that rhymes I like that
is part of my world now I know there so
what we want to do is after we answer
the questions is roll the clip from the
movie and everyone's gonna want to see
like the rocky montage JT and the
audience big Stallone fan and or the you
know the European scene but we're not
gonna do that we're gonna go with one of
the slower morning scenes today it's the
scene right before the day before when
he is having a talk with Adrian he's
laying down in bed with her and he's
he's basically telling her that his
whole life he's felt like a bum and I
really identified with that moment
because there was a time in my life
where well it's not time my life just
effect I didn't really finish high
school and I didn't to go to college I'm
like John who did both good for you and
for many years I was working odd jobs
and their Bo you know mmm I've like very
first relationship there's a lot of
relatives and family members who just
look down on me who didn't think I would
ever amount to anything
and finding YouTube was a big part of it
and what I love about this clip is it's
not about even winning it's just about
not giving up it's just about endurance
and you know as he says it's about going
the distance and I don't know I feel
like we got a lot of clips and I would
go into more depth but why we just show
that clip and just momentum going stable
in general like whip come on edge is
true there's nobody
that don't matter easy you know it's
always thinking i really don't matter if
I lose this like really don't matter if
this guy opens my head II all I wanted
to do is go to jesters I'm so glad we
played that clip first cuz it really
keeps the momentum rolling doesn't slow
down the pace of this while we were
watching that in the part about going
the distance I was thinking is this the
inspiration behind Michael Bolton's go
the distance for Hercules I think so
perhaps I was thinking it looks so much
like Stallone don't I I kind of got us
the lone look don't shake the head baby
over he's the same people now correct me
if I'm wrong Josh in that rocky scene
when he's looking up at the poster I
believe they actually really got it
wrong yeah wrote it into the movie that
he was gonna have the style yeah they
did and not mattering I think in him
pain just about and I kind of liked that
behind the scenes I think the whole
behind the scenes story of Rocky is
fascinating and something that is super
inspiring I think that just adds the
extra layer first of all that is already
inspirational and knowing does the
depths he had to go to be able to star
in this movie and to know like all the
technical things that went wrong too and
how much of a success it is I was
actually listen to an interview with
Conan O'Brien before we came over here
and he was talking about how
everything's gonna be difficult and
there's always gonna be obstacles and I
think the film behind the scenes and
infront of the camera is something that
is exceptionally inspiring John take it
away God was with the film inspire you
what's the film that inspires me well
many films today I chose a specific one
though I chose one that came out a
couple years ago called scene Street
which is yeah Irish kind of music it's a
lot slower than that Ron you look in the
lot
now anymore actually it's kind of a
medley of clips because why I learned in
sourcing these tonight is that it's
really hard to find sing Street clips
longer than a minute online okay all the
musical clips
well yes I didn't want to just like
we're not gonna just do riddle of the
model right now is what you're saying
there might be a little okay
but yeah I don't know that's a movie
that music is one of the biggest forces
in my world and so I always kind of
gravitate towards movies where it's
basically a collision of music and film
live because that's you know my two
greatest passions in life are those two
things and that particular movie was one
like the stuff I really want to see in
stuff that resonates with me most is
usually the stuff I wind up checking out
like when I have a couple hours spare
and I'm just on my own and so that was a
movie I kind of went to and bonded with
because it was very relatable in the
sense that it's like I went to Catholic
school growing up it takes place in a
private school and it's about this we
when we went to the same we met it was a
first grade with Alex Romano but it's
basically about it's a coming-of-age
story about this kid kind of overcoming
a circumstances by creating and you know
kind of making these unlikely
friendships forming a band and you know
unlocking life
the drabness of life that way and that's
kind of what music does for me that's
what friendships have led to special
like with you and with some of the
people even here tonight the sort of
creative things that can come out of
those little connections but the clips
is like I said it's kind of a medley so
the first one is from earlier in the
movie where the lead characters talking
to his brother basically about why do
you want to do this in the first place
because the characters starts off very
understated and kind of grows out of his
shell by the end of these spoilers you
know which is very again just a dynamic
I think we can all identify with and
especially for me I kind of feel like
him at the beginning of the movie and
I'm sort of trying to get to that point
evidence at the end of the movie but so
the first clip is where he's talking to
his brother kind of about to embark on
this journey and then in the middle
there's some music which I will kind of
touch on afterwards and then I also
chose a clip from kind of later on the
movie to demonstrate both the
transformation of that character because
of the power of art and also because of
a couple of the lines of dialogue
they're particularly resonant before we
get to that clip I want to know where
the two of you ever a band and why have
you not formed a band if that is the
case that you were not we've made songs
before for like weird little things
great way to each other though to each
other we live together now so when did
you first learn music or become
interested what was your first
instrument
I wanted to play since like I was since
as far as I can remember I borrow my
dad's and I want string guitar and bang
on it but it wasn't until like fifth
grade that I started taking like their
third third a third I started taking
like lessons and we have to play the
recorder and we all had to play the
recorder I'm just realizing this as
couples film therapy right now that's
the way it works and my girlfriend has
to accept that damn it Jen you don't
need to know how to play who are you
stay lead on you need to learn how not
to play a corner that's the trick that's
rock and roll and that takes practice
every school has a corresponding every
pub is a correspond every wedding has a
correspond and every Culver bond has a
middle-aged member they'll never know
whether they could have made it in music
industry or not because they never the
Bulls to write a song for someone else
rock and roll is a risk you risk being
ridiculed are the reason much of the
song in there is for the DIY aspect and
those clips overall because that's
something I kind of shrug
in general that whole part in the
beginning where he's talking about like
I don't know how to write a song really
we got to start somewhere we got to do
it right and at a certain point you just
gotta let go and make things and just
sort of play and explore and try things
out and that's something I feel like you
are very good at and I need to get
better at because I'm very sort of the
thought of cold and so I kind of
approach things like not writing like he
would at the beginning of that movie and
so I'm kind of in the process of
learning the arc to getting to that
place where you're you know telling off
the [ __ ] at school and then that
whole sentiment about you know you don't
know how to create you know you can only
stop things you know growing up with a
lot of opposition from the children
around me and stuff like those those
things you know you grow up with bullies
around like that the lesson becomes a
refuge that's sort of like if you can
create and that's what poetry and lyrics
and things like that are for means is
yeah way of processing that it's or yeah
you're a part of my your fuel for that
for me now so I do like how he becomes
the security guard later yeah then I
realized there's a redemptive moment for
him as well toss like half the stages
it's good well let's get into our second
question which is what is a film or a
scene from a film that triggers a memory
for you perhaps it's painful maybe it's
happy white chicks I had a very specific
situation when I
what checks they are gonna have to break
it down for me all right so dating this
girl wasn't okay a scene I for some
reason you know you the parentheses on
this question is happy or traumatic
right correct and I couldn't let you go
traumatic things so we're gonna do that
in once you punch in I'm gonna play a
slow scene and John's gonna play
something that's a lot more of deep
right kind of upbeat I actually don't
know your scene that's coming up yeah
you only care about we care about the
sketch would be wrong mom asks okay my
first thought was a part of my brain
would kind of go to like Raging Bull for
a second because you know I was a boxer
Rebecca that now it actually reminded me
of yeah I had that exact situation of my
brother once was really uncomfortable
because whenever Mike some dad's get in
a bad mood and when my dad was in a bad
mood they sounded exactly the same when
they would yell it was pretty it was
pretty weird when I would watch that
movie and the other movie that came to
my was pursuit of happiness but the one
that really gets to me like there's a
scene in a movie that really gets to me
it's the one when Robin Williams is
telling Matt Damon it's not your fault
we're gonna have so much fun today guys
fun stuff I bet you wanted flubber
no we yeah this specific scene identify
with I've been in therapy for a few
years and I remember when I first went
to therapy the film therapy just fits
doesn't it and when I first went to
therapy I did have a big wall up where I
just couldn't remember like the first
twenty-something years of my life and
eventually I started to understand what
I was learning but kind of like Matt
Damon it's like he could logically see
hey my cousin Jessica's here how you
doing
all eyes on her when I was talking about
therapy right now I'm just talking about
traumatic memories so the little is a
and then in that way in that scene it's
like he he's logically able to pinpoint
what's wrong with him but the issue is
he can't feel it and he needs to break
through that barrier he needs to break
through that wall and I used to you know
in the years of therapy I was diagnosed
with several things PTSD type 2 bipolar
and ADHD so I used to be really on like
a lot of medication and a big part of
being able to get off meds and be able
to heal grow is learning to embrace the
emotions first is to embrace it so you
can start letting go and another part of
this scene that I think is really
powerful is when you say it's not your
fault it has me think of a commode which
is a the quote went take full
responsibility for your life what may
have happened to you now up until this
point is not entirely your fault but
from now on it is and I kind of feel
like in this moment it's him taking
charge of his life and not being
dictated by his past experiences did I
say that well did that come across well
to myself intelligent when I thought
yeah very cool Carly's point did you
decide like I don't want to be taking it
was it was a year a year and a half ago
actually when I I had gone through a
breakup I used to go by his personal
name running around on the internet and
then when I wanted to change that and I
wanted to just embrace myself the
process of it was very challenging
because I was on like adderall 40
milligrams which was very addicting I
was taking that every day for years and
then I had to start weaning off of that
and I do there's a lot of weaning off
and a lot of exercising that I took up
you know where la I took a meditation
and
do that everyday yeah your app that you
don't have
I do yeah I started off in that space
actually and that is a great everyone is
everyone should try it so I started
meditating I started exercising and I
should start dieting I lost like 30
pounds of the course that and then the
day I would realize I lost 30 pounds I
met my girlfriend I was very confident
that today it's all because the
weight-loss winery here in that chair
today so yeah why show this clip was
just talking more about that yeah well I
want to know yeah yeah I know am I
talking about it yeah it was very it was
it was tough and I'm not perfect you
know when I still have my time so I get
really upset but I'm a lot calmer than
I've ever been quicker to apologize and
I'm more self aware that I've ever been
to there's people in this room who have
seen me in very manic phases actually so
for those who don't point you out this
guy right there the manic phases they
could go on for hours and then they've
gone for hours and I'd be like very
belittling and it was one of those
things where I was speaking of Raging
Bull ger times I kind of felt like I was
that guy and over I was just into a rage
I felt like I could be kind of
emotionally abusive at that if that was
the word for it it wasn't like
physically harming people but
emotionally which is pretty pretty bad
stuff I think and yeah I feel
comfortable talking about it now has
been so long where I talk about it but
yeah I mean this is fun right this is
fun fun conversations we're having we're
learning we're learning a lot about my
own therapy and John goes to therapy -
so you better open up about you
oh yeah we're going outside the spectrum
and a couple yeah that's gonna be great
I think really quick the fascinating
part about John and I and we're so
similar is I feel like some of my
laundry came from my puffery but when I
went to school I was a very different
kind of person we went to the same
school and I was like a funny guy had a
great time whereas John's family who's
right there next to my brother actually
John's family's like the nicest pens
you don't ever mean I like the sister -
hi Diana John's parents are like the
best parents ever and but his stuff was
like from the schooling time right yeah
yeah we had the opposite I'm gonna call
it John's drama
just expose him for the rest of it
you could probably put yeah anyway let's
watch that hilarious clip in Good Will
Hunting it's not your fault don't [ __ ]
with me all right don't [ __ ] me Sean not
you it's not your fault
[Music]
attention a release would you ever hug
your therapist situation no I wanted to
say to like when Robin Williams says
like you know like [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] it's it's not that if you're
diagnosed with something that it's not
valid I think a big part would help me
let go of stuff was not being defined by
what I was diagnosed by and I feel like
that's kind of what Robin Williams is
trying to also communicate there so I
don't know if there's anyone in this
crowd or whoever were recording this
right now but I was watching it that a
lot of times people will just keep using
that diagnosis as an affirmation I feel
like sometimes I think it's a good thing
to affirm it and it's a good thing to
like get in touch with it
sometimes though it does become a crutch
or an excuse you just leave it at that
yeah so I just really love that scene
and does make me cry like an awful lot
side note
side tip crying is more powerful than
most medications actually did you know
that Briana it's all crying right now
let's do it one big cry fest like a good
cry man yeah and you like what you have
to say about like he's not trying to
lower any sort of diagnosis or belittle
it or in any way say that it's not valid
there's some things where I feel like
you know I suffer from depression and I
feel like I there are days where I'm
like I wish there was a catalyst for
this like I wish there was a reason why
I'm feeling this way but there's not and
then I just feel like bad that there's
not like great we're just going to over
and over again
that's life let's talk about happiness
and Letran in fact I mean the movie I
chose is a happier film overall but the
scenes I chose are kept on the exterior
side I approached this this night partly
because I'm indecisive but also Gemini's
so I try to pick things that have this
or dual quality in some way shape or
form and I thought about a lot of movies
because the the whole like time and
place thing like what film triggers in
memory there are so many of those
especially growing up in like a film
household it's like the Marx Brothers
take me back or clueless takes me back
or I mean st. Louie takes me back like
movies like that
Zoolander we're gonna watch a close do
it so for this one I chose a movie that
I just found as I recall this I just
found it in the paper one day they were
just doing one of those advanced
screenings that they advertise and sell
tickets to him which used to happen
every once in awhile and that's how I
first wound up seeing School of Rock and
school of robbing is the movie that I
really loved and it was one of them -
like family favorites that I found so
you know it's kind of special to me in
that regard but it's also you know the
the journey of the movie whimsical
though it maybe is about a guy kind of
shaping up his life and there's a lot of
frustration in it that gets aired out
both on the kids side and on you know
the Jack Black side and the two clips I
chose the first one is a pretty
noticeable monologue but the highlight
for me is the second clip because
there's at least one speech that Joan
Cusack gives to Jack Black that just
resonates like so hard with me because
I'm a pretty anxious person and you know
social situations people really tripping
up my mind is always crunching at every
moment no matter who I'm talking to no
matter how comfortable I wanna be with
them just every moment has me wound up
and that's actually I think the name of
that chapter that I chose for that
second clip is called er wound up and
the first clip kind of echoes mine and
many people just frustrations with life
in general because that's the side of me
I don't air as much the frustrated side
of me I don't have
lying to a member connected to I don't
know how to express it's fine I feel
like in a way we have if we isolate
toxicity and make a gang out of it
you have the angry half and I have the
sat out and so like that's right one's
much more kinetic but yeah and that's
kind of these all these questions kind
of people lead together for me a little
bit you know also double team in your
choices yeah yeah yeah this is this
could be easily question three or
something like that but yeah in terms of
like a time in place this is conjure
kind of a joyous memory because I wasn't
bonding days was me and my dad we went
out and checked this movie out I just
thought the kid was the drummer look
cool on poster and you know cool is what
you want to be when you're not and
you're growing up thing and yeah so
school bro how old were you when you saw
this what year did it come out sounds
like three four yeah 13 alright so we're
gonna look through our eyes as the 13
year old when we watch this clip yeah
roll that beautiful bean footage
I wasn't always around this tight there
was a time when I was fun I was funny
but you can't be funny and be the
principal of a prep school no and and if
anything goes wrong it's my head in the
Smasher
these parents will come down on me like
a nuclear bomb I can't make a mistake I
gotta be perfect and that pressure has
turned me into one thing that I never
wanted to be no you're not yes I am I am
they are that was very challenging what
agent credit afford to well that's your
problem right there
there's a big range Rider 1 I don't have
the mind for that ok you're a teacher I
was a former teacher and you still have
my credential the one thing that bothers
me about anything that's in a classroom
is they go about with a chalkboard
behind them which is you know in no
classrooms remember is there a
chalkboard so why are we still doing
this it's a smart board now the world is
coming down on you you can't be you have
to understand all-in feel very well I
mean like swap go granted none of my
stakes are as high as several parents at
an overpriced school but you know that's
those two monologues are kind of the
dueling voices I have to stave off in my
head a lot of the time because it's easy
for me to feel dejected like what's the
point you know because especially mental
struggles are just kind of perpetual and
you have to train your brain against
them and acknowledge some days you're
gonna be loving you know and so I guess
I kind of chose those yes sort of one
half of the frustration and the other
half of just everything to a degree
equates to that level of pressure so I
spend a lot of time tense in ways that
I've only just recently started to
acknowledge are also physical like you
know you'll feel tightness or
butterflies and when you actually catch
them and realize that their sensations
you don't feel at all times then you
realize oh maybe everybody doesn't feel
like this you know maybe that is me and
our parts of me anyway and so yeah
that's kind of where that that we came
from how do you feel right now
a little jittery I'm mostly worried that
I'm not articulating these things well
enough and I'm wasting everyone's time
and I'm also having in the background
there's a fun program running
haha getting to know us guys let's get
into our final question time
Oh what what third question
yeah yeah another question yeah yeah
that's true we do prepare what is it
that helps you through difficult times
we already brought why she came yeah I
would probably say okay my answer to
this one is I just want to say really
quick well I love Britney cuz brands
when he came up with film therapy on on
her channel and the reason I love her
segment is because it reminds me of two
things one is it does when I hear
conversations on film therapy it does
remind me that films even subconsciously
we might not realize it aren't escape
and another thing too is we can also
identify what people and all and
sometimes you get some good inspiration
from people as well and the movie 8 mile
really does inspire the hell out I mean
we're gonna write battle now people
let's do in the movie it kind of goes
hand in hand because I see I I know
about Eminem's personal life because
we're buddies you know
yes Mario and I thought in a movie 8
mile it's the final rap battle if you
guys haven't seen the movie we're gonna
spoil the whole damn thing for you right
now in the final scene when he's doing
this rap battle because early on in the
movie he's just trying to be another
rapper and in that in the finale when
he's doing his rap elegance anthony
mackie Falcon from the vendor's he this
doesn't really even insult him for most
of it he kind of just insults himself
the whole time right because he's
embracing all these qualities about him
that often times were told to like not
showcase to not be vulnerable about or
feel ashamed about or feel guilty about
and instead he embraces it and I think
just mmm as an artist is a big thing
that's inspired me about him is he's
someone who just kind of embraced all
the craziness in his life and just put
that on public display kind like a
public therapy kind of we're getting
meta here because I'm saying that like
he's playing defense like if I say at
first he can't say it back to me yeah he
doesn't have anything to say I've heard
a big part letting go of anything or
being able to grow is just first
important in yourself and I feel like in
that's in this scene that we're gonna
show as a final repel is
he is just doing that he is embracing
all the [ __ ] people have given him and
all the things he knows her shitty about
his life no matter how bad it can look
it's just this ability to not care to
not give a [ __ ] and I feel like when you
get to a point like that where you just
don't give a [ __ ] anymore that can be
life changing
of course there are times where I give a
[ __ ] I kind of give a [ __ ] right now I'm
going to turn on eight miles
it's like watching The Pursuit of
Happyness and not watching anything is
like hot pressed finale of this movie
and then once you get there you're like
that's right
[ __ ] everyone else I'm just going to
embrace me yeah and I feel like this
movie does that and
yeah yeah that's pretty much it they
wishes for others energies but unlike
the other one who knows the rap to this
many damage and play the clip
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah I mean you're gonna do your own
battles yeah I feel like I said
everything I know we tend to do the
thing where I set it up and then we talk
about it after move over I I do I feel
like whenever I get back in that state
of it's like there's a fine line between
not caring about people are not being
considerate and then not caring what
people think about you you know like
there's a difference there and not
letting opinions dictate you and
sometimes I can still fall into that
habit but whatever I see that or listen
to a couple Eminem songs I'm like yeah
I'm alright anyway I forgot what your
answer was for the next one John oh good
nice for everyone yes so for the next
one I actually chose a couple again to
kind of stitch together one is a more
intense moment and then the other one is
a much welcomed moment of levity but
basically I chose a clip from both
ParaNorman and a clip from Swiss Army
man because both of those are our movies
that I would kind of call on for
difficult times one you know how you
like listen to an aggressive or a sad
song when you're feeling that way to
kind of get that out that's kind of why
it shows ParaNorman and then the
opposite and for Swiss Army man because
there is as much life and melancholy as
there is a new surface of that movie
there is also this weird palpable joy
I've never seen a movie quite like Swiss
Army man
I consider actually for the second
question because I just so remember the
time that I saw that I mean how can
anyone forget when they see Swiss Re
bandits it's really original film isn't
it you just don't forget yeah it's it's
inexplicable and uncanny and I find it
interesting that that movie starts out
you know with a guy trying to end his
life and then learning kind of
confronting life and learning the value
of it through his strange whimsical
interactions with the corpse he finds
washed up on the beach so there is a
very strong I see you like raising an
eyebrow is very strange but going back
to the first clip you know growing up
was not always the easiest like in
school especially like with the other
kids and things you know people weren't
overly friendly even my friends weren't
overly friendly and so you know the clip
goes into a much broader context not you
you were good so those people are there
and I don't know how you remember it
but ParaNorman is a movie again with
like a really easily identifiable
character for me because you know that's
my kid who like loves horror movies and
stuff and that's me and I've always felt
a little bit misfit I think a lot of
people do but you know especially
growing up just you know being given
what for a lot of the time from the
people around you you can start to get
very warped and angry and one thing I
realized over time as I got to know more
people in high school who had the same
kind of stories I did was the places
that you fall after that and the way you
process that information can be wildly
different and so I've met people who had
had I feel like those experiences
growing up dealing with you know people
being shitty to you have taught me a lot
of my best qualities they've also given
me a lot of my worst qualities but
they've also taught me a lot about
understanding people and about
understanding what is personal and what
is just the byproducts of other people's
circumstances and that's kind of what
this clip cuts to is what people do with
their traumas and also their fear fear
is another big sort of force in my life
that I'm trying to dismantle and rail
against because you know anxiety is just
the hyper concentrated version of fear
it's just this kind of like what's the
outcome going to be of every moment and
especially seeing that movie for the
first time I was like wow this was not
the message is more sophisticated than I
was expecting for a movie that is you
know I feel like every animated movie
gets just kind of packaged up and
pitched as kids but a ParaNorman to me
is more of just like a family accessible
movie with a message that was so much
more nuanced than i thought it would be
about fear what it does to people what
it causes people to do because they just
don't understand and you know I mean the
movie borrows from the Witch Trials and
that's just one big lesson and what
people do when they don't get it and I
freaked out and I feel like we are all
subject to what people don't get and
freak out about a lot and I feel like so
many conflicts arise because people I
feel like a lot of people attribute
conflict to people being conniving or
malicious when it's truly to me the
opposite is just people not thinking
enough or considering enough we're
getting enough in touch and so yeah
that's that's why I chose the paranormal
clip and then after that partly for the
levity and partly for just the opposite
side of that coin because both of those
movies have a darkness at their core of
melancholy kind of aura but one is a
little more in that vein the other is
much more joyous to kind of you know
interact with and so one of these is
very intense and dialogue driven and one
of them is very sensory I'm so good with
the vocabulary I do like or even try
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
never see this with sorry man there
probably thank you yeah I just find it's
a very it is a very unique and strange
for me but it is one that especially I
don't know partly why I chose that cliff
a was to be palate cleanser and B was to
just the visual representation of the
joy of life I thought was a nice thing
because I feel like life is beautiful
and I have a hard time tapping into the
joy of living it and so that clip
especially like the movie itself is kind
of again about a guy learning to want to
living and learning about the joy of
life again through this weird little
experience and that's you know in terms
of like what helps you through a tough
time
that sort of lust for life is very
palpable from that movie for me and it
just is a creative type that movie
inspired me also just because I have not
seen very many movies like that at all
and had something to say about that
first clip it's kind of well I've never
seen ParaNorman but I felt like that
clip really compartmentalized how the
thought process behind why someone is a
bully which could be something that
maybe I would show to my daughter
because it's something that she's seven
years old and has been dealing with you
know some sadness with a friend and and
knowing that it's not it's not about her
it's about the other person's internal
struggle that they're going on with them
that was one of the most important
lessons I ever learned is I feel like
that kind of helped me because I haven't
met like when he talks to her Dean is
like no you're doing exactly what they
do just in a different direction like
I've seen that become so many people
that I've met over time where you'll see
the the mean streaks that come out of
people because of the justification that
they were treated that way themselves so
why shouldn't I give this back and I
understand I've always kind of seen that
instinct and it's not one that really
clicks with me anything that's kind of
indicative of why is that mess
for whatever reason got through my head
really young and I'm grateful for that
but when I saw this movie I kind of had
a similar thought so what you said just
now is like we see a lot of kids movies
with a lot of messages about being you
and that being okay and that's a good
message too but when I saw this I was
like oh that's a unique message and
that's a well expressed message and you
know it's easy to feel preaching and I
don't feel like that movie gets preachy
hardly at all so yeah and they feel like
horror at all it's a lot of fun I
haven't seen either of those movies but
I completely understood everything that
went wanted thing that follows a great
Swiss Army man it might still do the
Amazon Prime if you have it I will make
sure to add that to my queue immediately
it's probably how John got a clip okay
so we have a fourth question yeah last
one of the night people
you guys have endured oh I appreciate so
much who is a character you especially
admire or identify with in film Batman
[Music]
you wanted to talk about that my mom
still around so does really can't Martha
[Music]
it's funny said the set angry thing and
I'm about to capitalize on that right
now
ah ice this movie when I saw this movie
there's no movie character right now
that when I watch it I go I identify
with that character I can't think of a
movie right now just that unique people
but when I watched this movie at this
time I really did identify with it and
then once I tell you the movie you're
gonna be like oh yeah Ryan Gosling and
drive
obviously ng C this is so apparent you
are stuck I'm just that badass I've done
so many crimes though yeah that was
totally me no it was what I identified
about that I mean and that's kind of a
performance that's sort of open to
interpretation I guess but at that time
in my life I did feel like I was rather
an empty guy and I could see that
performance as a dude who feels empty
but then feels emotion for a girl and
and that as time I might even reference
like specific girls at the time in my
life there it was more about like if you
had a crush on someone or if I wasn't a
relationship and when you do fall in
love you do want to be like a protector
a hero but then sometimes that can be
like a dark
romance that sort of forms from that and
like I'm grateful now that the
relationship I'm in is the best
relationship I've ever been it's like
shake your head just rush to stand up
and then shake say I can joke like that
but then she'll yell at me for joking
like that are you doing no then and then
there's the scene that I'm gonna show
and if you guys do not like violence
you're gonna want to turn away on this
one it is the most violent scene in the
whole movie it's the head smashing scene
amazing who has seen Drive in this crowd
half the crowd
right here
yeah in this moment I think I think hey
brother
that's how when the volume down it's a
nice microphone you got away it's in
this scene what happens is he keep
finally kisses the woman he loves or I
don't know has feelings for I don't know
he loves her kind of seems like that but
then afterwards he exposes the sight in
him that he's always kind of feared to
show her and then she's kind of scared
of that and at that time but don't worry
guys is right after it I have another
clip that is very totally different than
this one and I think I just wanted an
excuse to play this clip is one of my
favorite scenes of all time so Jing or
Aria I'm not gonna be watching you
should watch
[Music]
yeah that's exactly what we went down
that day I lost 30 pounds when I killed
some guy all right okay now the next
things from Dumb and Dumber all right
the reason why is because as a guy a guy
who's a movie buff might see a scene
like that and go identify with the
emotions of that guy I want to protect
my woman like that and then there's a
scene in Dumb and Dumber Lerner he's fat
everyone hears you dumb and dumber those
people
he's fantasizing about when he meets
stuff put Mary and how he would like
meet the family and he'd be the
highlight of the party and he would save
her like stand up for her it'd be a
badass action hero at a restaurant and
to me that's more of the reality of my
life like I watch Drive and I go I'm so
much like that then I'll fantasize about
like saving my girlfriend or something
I'm like oh I'm this stupid or I'm going
to dump it over like this is never gonna
happen is it so yeah let's play that
scene from Dumb and Dumber to show the
real version of how boys fantasize about
protecting their woman
[Music]
there's a buggy headache I don't want to
fight anymore
but even the fantasy part where I look
it's he gets his ass kicked by the chef
first and every time I fantasize about
being a badass in front of my girl it
always starts with like I'm able to take
a few hits first and then I could fight
that's never gonna happen
yeah and then situation on that area but
I won't have to go first I have to go I
knew weapons - yeah you admire endure
yeah ok so I chose for this last one are
on the lighter side all right
but yeah it's the first one you know I
view myself as an awkward guy and
especially when it comes to socializing
talking with human beings you know off
the doming it kind of like what we're
doing right now and feel free to use
that
so the first clip I chose was from a
film that we saw first at a test
screening just you know time placing it
again Chad's - question - but we saw I
Love You Man and Paul Rudd in that movie
I identify so so hard with and the scene
I chose is pretty much every
conversation I attempt to have at least
from my point of view with most people
and the second clip might shows us from
my favorite film which is Ed Wood which
again shouts out - question - it always
takes me back to my one of my dearest
friends back there Aaron and I saw that
on my 20th birthday at the stroke of
midnight at the Nuart
I think it was a film projection but I
can't be certain but that's a character
who I've always identified with and been
fascinated by mostly because of that
movie and I've seen a few of that Woods
actual films but something about that
figure as a person who you know clearly
has the spirit and clearly wants to get
out there and make things but it's also
kind of terrible at it is is like a very
real thing that I
like afraid I think anybody who creates
afraid of being that is afraid of
pouring your heart and soul into
something that ultimately wins it
laughably terrible and the message I
think beyond that at least the movies
message beyond that is it it almost
doesn't matter really and once you can
get past that level of like it's got to
be great as long as you put you into it
as long as you fight for your vision you
know you do the best that you can with
what you think is right you know that's
what it's really about that's what
creation is really for that's what all
these things are you know and and Ed
Wood too I mean over the course that
movie just you know he looks out for you
know the people he cares about and
there's just something about that
performance bummer to watch Johnny Depp
do whatever is happening to Johnny Depp
right now I feel like Johnny Depp is
kind of like a pumpkin have you ever
seen those time-lapse but that character
in the wait.you plays that character is
the energy everything I just I really
love that I've always been drawn to and
I kind of fear and identify with that
character all at the same time but again
you know that that movie kind of packs
it up in a nice play so that's my my -
hey Peter it's Sydney Clavin no that's
not right Oh Sydney it's Peter Klaven I
met you last week at an open house and
I'm sorry I forgot what its gonna say
what was he saying
ah mr. wills
is it all worth it it is when it works
you know the one film of mine where I
had total control King the studio hated
it but they didn't get to touch a frame
bad visions are worth fighting for
why spend your life making someone
else's dreams
[Music]
now I'm never gonna thank you Johnny
Depp other than sweet a rotting pumpkin
yeah that's for you guys whether you see
a monkey or Johnny Depp you'll be
reminded there you know plan 9 from
outer space to is that are you that is
yeah Hollywood just call Jeff Hollywood
just call hey we got a hot take it's
coming back into vindaloo we need to
rethink they tried to remake play nine
you know that I did there was a teaser
trailer happen that's the movie that
he's making right there then yeah that's
probably a famous yeah movie I would say
although there were a few that I in just
second hand caught the titles of growing
up if you have a psychotronic book on
him but yeah I don't know just that just
that I've never viewed myself as a
person with tons of audacity but I guess
that's kind of what I take out of a
cliff like then especially the little
nudge from a hero that sort of like
visions or any part of my senior quote
actually well I spend your life making
somebody else's dreams but yeah you know
like that just that fortification of
yeah audacity I feel like that's kind of
a theme that runs throughout that movies
like even comes out in from the cruise
like I gotta get comfortable so I'm just
gonna wear the anger in the wig and be
comfortable and direct and like in weird
ways I admire things like that because
I'm like oh I'm usually very kind of
packaged up and trying not to discomfort
anybody else around me so not that I you
know have that same predilection or
anything but just that openness to just
kind of go for your vision
uncompromising lead not second-guess
yourself every step of the way I think
he could have used a little
second-guessing perhaps but but yeah
that ultimate theme and you know as for
the creative realm at all like that
movie has always really inspired me and
also really resonated with me and yeah
there's a reason why that's my favorite
well thank you Jim I'm thinking Drake
I heard joining me for this session they
came bringing Arabi and Thank You Stacey
and he gave us these shirts that were
wearing and he drove like six hours to
come here two parters and we know like
happy you guys already good yeah
I feel like we're on a character arc
pulling we start off a little bit on the
you know the downer side and then we get
on the right now oh you're gonna do that
for us it's not so easy when you guess
[Music]
what all right well thank you all
[Applause]